We have been talking a lot of about interfaces and how useful they are, now I
would like to bring up a related topic called inheritance, and interface
specifies behavior that the class that implements it should exhibit.
Inheritance can do a little better than that, when a class inherits from
another class it picks up behavior and data. Here is an example of a set of
classes, where one would probably use inheritance, to model them. We have a
class vehicle, it's a very general class. A car is a special kind of a vehicle,
a motorcycle is another kind of a vehicle, a truck is a kind of vehicle. And an
SUV is a kind of car. Now you would use inheritance not interfaces in this
situation because you could put common data into the vehicle class. Such as the
weight of the vehicle, the number of wheels, things like that. Now you might
say why not always use inheritance? It seems better. But there are two issues
with it. One is, it is complex, and also a class can only inherit from one
class, whereas a class can implement as many interfaces as it likes. A bit of
terminology, the class from which one inherits is called the super-class, and
the class that does the inheriting is called the sub-class. We would say truck
is a sub-class of vehicle. Vehicle, has a super-class, of truck. Just to see
that you're paying attention, let me ask you, what are the sub-classes of car?
What are the super-classes of car, the sub-classes of SUV, and the
super-classes of SUV, in our inheritance hierarchy over here? Just put your
answers into these boxes.